après tu vas faire le point et pilot
dans les paddocks d'accords locaux
flambant neufs personnel aux petits
soins ou refuge de la ferme d aubry les
équidés saisis par la justice trouve la
paix et le calme sur cette propriété
coeur du berry ils réapprennent à vivre
sans contrainte entre guillemets la
seule contrainte qu'ils ont c'est un
respect mutuel entre nous c'est à dire
que on leur offre un site où ils vivent
correctement d'inconfort hollande manque
juste de va pas me taper panneaux mordre
et c'est donc c'est vraiment une
confiance mutuelle qui se met et une
relation qui se crée différente avec
chaque individu
[Musique]
185 hectares une capacité d'accueil de
900 animaux ici ce qui marque en premier
c'est l'espace poneys ânes et chevaux se
retrouve au grand air après des années
de maltraitance un lieu unique en europe
un lieu qui n'auraient pas pu voir le
jour sans les donateurs et les bénévoles
c'est les dons et effectivement les legs
et c'est vraiment je suis d'une
reconnaissance infinie à tous ceux qui
nous aident qui nous ont aidés et
vraiment il peut voir voilà le résultat
de douves à l'argent qu'on a pu récolter
avec un million quatre d'euros de frais
de fonctionnement annuels le refuge est
toujours dépendant des dons aujourd'hui
la ferme accueille 400 équidés ici les
animaux peuvent finir leurs vieux jours
en toute tranquillité